bien restons dans le domaine des
exploits sportifs car c'est une
remarquable performance qu'a réalisée
cette nuit un jeune boxeur de 24 ans
leon spinks qui a battu à las vegas le
fameux mohamed-ali cassius clay si vous
préférez il a battu aux points et lui a
donc ravi la couronne de champion du
monde des poids lourds
cassius clay à 36 ans alors est-ce le
début de la fin dans le voir sur ces
images
ça devait arriver un jour bien sûr en
france et fera tout de même que ceux-ci
s'interrompre à un règne de 80 ce qui
apparut curieux d'après ces images c'est
l'attitude de claix qui n'a pas toujours
donné l'impression de défendre ses
chances avec son talent habituel mais ce
n'est peut être qu'une impression du dc
de paris certes celui qui se dit depuis
longtemps le plus beau le plus grand le
plus fort à 36 ans spinks 24 seulement
ceci explique en partie cela
c'est en 1964 que clay est devenu
champion du monde pour la première fois
vous en souvenez peut-être en battant
liston il a détendu 22 fois sa couronne
et avance pin's seul frasier norton
l'avait battue la défaite de cette nuit
annonce peut-être la fin d'un règne mais
on n'est pas prêt d'oublier clay c'était
un personnage hors pair il ya eu tort
cependant le mésestimé son adversaire
qu'il avait réutilisé avant le combat en
l'appelant par dérision le castor en
raison de sa dentition